[Applause]
all right y'all we always like to close
out the hour with something that might
make you smile one last story to give
you all the feels sometimes i save the
best stories for last you're welcome
this is what i'm liking
[Applause]
[Applause]
right now
student loan partner pilot pin makers of
g2 the go to pin at the kelly clarkson
show want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you who dream
big so they're gonna be writing you a
check for a thousand dollars how's that
sound
oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
as a mama there is nothing like watching
my kids smile and light up when they see
me it's adorable it's awesome it makes
you feel good well one mom decided to
record her son's reactions when she
picked him up from daycare she captured
him nearly every day for five years and
it's straight up adorable and awesome
hey jax
okay
[Music]
i love it i kid you not that is
literally my son remy he's the same way
it makes me feel so good um we have this
and her five-year-old son jackson on the
line right now what's up y'all
i'm not even kidding that's my my
daughter does not do that but my son
does that every time i get home he just
gets so excited it makes you feel so
good
yeah it's the best feeling ever
did you know that you're famous jackson
that everybody loves you yes it is
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh jackson we love you keep getting
excited i promise you you make your
mama's day keep keep being excited every
time thank you so much jackson thank you
thank you i'm liking your post right now
when you think of a bird watcher you
poorly envisioned someone with
binoculars but a woman in upstate new
york wanted something more up close so
check out what she did
[Music]
that's one way to do it uh let's get
this innovative naturist on the line
what's up our lady jordan
you are so cute i love this so much but
before we talk about that face feeder
invention um you study birds for a
living right absolutely um i am a wild
bird research technician which basically
means that i go out into the wild i
humanely capture wild birds and i study
them um but about a year ago i made a
tick tock account and recently i had
been tagged a whole bunch of times in
this video where this guy who feeds
hummingbirds has all these contraptions
on his face
and i was like you know what i think i
can do that so i went downstairs and i
found the only pair of glasses that i
had laying around which were these with
these uh eyelashes on them
and i made this little face feeder and
sat outside for about 45 minutes all
bundled up in my blanket and then a bird
came and i've been hooked ever since oh
my god i mean do you how long does it
generally take for a bird to do that
though do you have to sit there for
hours often sometimes sometimes it can
take any anywhere from just a minute or
two to up to three hours and so i sit
outside and you know minus freezing
temperatures and and i'm all bundled up
in either my blanket or my ghillie suit
that i went out and i got
and i just sit and i watch and i wait
and what you guys don't get to see is
that the birds are all around me hopping
around talking to each other and it's
like my own little private nature show
and so it's just it's amazing and i'm
hooked
i love it you
make me smile thank you so much bird
lady jiren i'm liking your posts right
now right
thank you
some of the best moments are when you
catch your child being totally
themselves and they have no idea you're
watching it's awesome case in point a
mom in ohio took this amazing video of
her 12 year old son just getting down
y'all
you need to watch the whole video he is
my new favorite person on planet earth
the whole video will bring you so much
joy um can we talk about though how
lucky the mom is that her son's even
doing laundry that's amazing
he looks happy doing it that's amazing
we'll ask her a tip on that so christina
and her son shane are on the line right
now what's up
oh my god
shane i'm gonna get to you because i
love you but christina i'm gonna start
with you i'm speaking for every mom what
is your secret
in getting your child to do laundry
well the secret is shane has a cell
phone
and uh
he is very motivated to do his laundry
and things around the house because if
not he gets his phone taken away so
that's like the big key is he has to do
his laundry in order to keep his phone
so but he's a pretty good kid anyways so
even if he didn't have a cell phone he'd
still be doing his laundry for sure so
i love that so shane
everybody is dying to know what were you
jamming out to my man
um
i was listening to erica banks um
i just kind of felt in the moment i was
busted by erica banks oh yeah busted it
by goku banks i just kind of
look at those things in the moment i
felt like myself i
when she told me that she posted the
video on tick-tock i was like okay and i
didn't think there was much gonna happen
i just thought there would be a couple
likes and maybe a couple of views but um
it just blew up i mean overnight i mean
it was like
there was like a thousand likes a minute
we did not expect especially from small
town hicksville ohio we just were not
expecting it and shane used to dance
like that all the time when he was
younger and then he hit like a certain
age where he just
he didn't do it anymore because it was
too cool too cool so
um it was nice to see it because
everyone in the comments were like how
did you get him to do his laundry and
how are you not busting out laughing
it's it was more like a joy moment for
me because when he was younger he did
that all the time and it was more like
seeing a little bit of his childhood
back back into our lives was nice well
and i gotta tell you shane
the best part is that we're all you we
all do that just not everyone's videoing
us so like that's why it's so relatable
and we all love it so much you got some
moves man you can shake those hips boy
uh thank you so much shane thank you
christine i'm liking y'all's quotes
right now
[Applause]
tick tock has turned lots of regular
people into bona fide stars and one of
the most unexpected is 79 year old kenny
jerry kenny's a navy vet who served
during the cuban missile crisis
kenny has such a big personality and
kind heart his neighbor amanda started
the channel documenting his everyday
life
now he's known to his 1.3 million fans
as patriotic kenny so it's no surprise
when kenny's mobility scooter broke down
the tick tock community was quick to
help
oh my goodness
oh my god
oh my goodness
oh my gosh i think she's stopping
what you're honking your horn
this is right this is all yours
and that's not all kenny's fans raised
so much money um over 100 000 and
counting actually um that they're
donating dozens of scooters to other
veterans let's get kenny and his
neighbor amanda in here what's up y'all
[Applause]
well hello to both of you uh mckinney
you're looking sharp and also thank you
so much for your service
thank you
well amanda can you tell us more about
why you started the tick tock channel
sure i would love to
well you know kenny he started learning
sign language in part after we met i
teach at a deaf school and my friends
and family jenny his buddy jerry are all
deaf and so he was learning asl and i
started posting videos about that
journey then the scooter broke down
and i posted a video and really i just
knew that people in our community love
kenny and the world would love kenny and
i was right i just didn't expect it to
be that right
you're a hit kenny well kenny
what does it mean that so many people
stepped up to help you it seemed like it
really affected you it was so beautiful
when you found out that scooter was
yours
yes what did that mean to me
it meant the world to me
you know it's just it's so awesome
for that scooter that i got i never
thought that would happen in my life
believe me
oh my god well i couldn't think of a
better person to give it to you are such
a sweetheart and you're so fun and
you're such a light thank you so much
amanda for sharing these videos and
thank you kenny for joining us i'm
liking your posts right now right
i'm going to show you how to check your
oil today it's really easy to do just
make sure your automobile is relatively
level and that it's been sitting for a
while then the big fish is going to swim
on the back side of the rock
come over the top
i know it's hard to see and the big fish
is going to drop down through the
waterfall
then you cinch it up
oh my god i love the big fish
bo started the tick tock channel called
dad advice from bo with his daughter
emily i love it and we have him on the
line now
what's up bo what's up emily
hey
nice to see you
okay so i bo i'm assuming that this was
more emily's idea at first
oh absolutely
in real life i'm actually a very private
person
so
when
emily proposed this idea to me i
immediately rejected it i didn't want to
have anything to do with it
but she's very persistent she kept
coming back to me day after day and she
always had a new reason to do it a new
idea for me and then she came up with
this one this one day where she said
listen
you have a dad that you're always able
to go to for advice whenever you want
which i still do
and all the kids have you
but what if there's somebody out there
that doesn't have a dad what if there's
somebody out there that could use that
kind of advice don't you want to make
some videos for them yeah right i had to
agree that's not a bad idea so yeah we
started making a couple of videos and
the responses that we've gotten have
been just amazing yeah and she's
she's totally right emily's totally
right some of us didn't grow up with a
dad around uh luckily i did have some
good guy friends that did tell me how to
you know change a tire and do my oil
change my wall but um but there's emily
there's another reason that you started
this channel can you share that with us
yeah i wish that it was just a genius
idea but it was really boring out of
desperation i
suffered a traumatic brain injury in a
soccer game and it happened to the back
of my head so you can't see it on my
face but my body is very sick and so um
in 2020
try not to cry i just said to my parents
like i don't want to keep fighting
anymore i don't have anything left in me
and so starting the tick tock was just
my attempt to do something every day and
um i thought i could put something good
out in the world but what we got was an
army of people just fighting for me and
telling me to keep going
um and i don't there's a lot of people
with my type of brain injury in the
world and a lot of good dads so i don't
know why we got chosen to have this
blessing but we will do everything we
can to pay it forward
absolutely how are you doing right now
emily are you doing better
i'm okay um i'm fighting really hard and
because of tick-tock and the
money we've earned i get to go to a
brain injury clinic next week and try to
get really really well
okay all right
hey well please please let us know if we
can help in any way i didn't know that
part of this story so plea please let us
know if we can help and i have to say is
this where you all live this beautiful
log cabin
yeah we are very lucky in the in the
middle of the woods oh my god i just
wanted to say your whole show is just
about good people and how much good
there is in the world and i think um in
the last couple of years a lot of people
started to question that but we just
want to reiterate there is so much good
in this world
absolutely emily
emily
you're breaking me right now oh my god i
wish you were here i want to hug you um
i don't know where you are but i'd come
i love a log cabin and i love being out
in the middle of nowhere um says the
girl who owns a ranch in montana so i'm
i'm down with wherever you are
thank you all so much and good luck with
whatever treatment you're gonna you're
gonna do and and let us know please if
we can help you in any way bo thank you
so much for helping everybody out there
that maybe didn't have a daddy to teach
them stuff like that
i'm liking y'alls posts right now
[Applause]
changes
[Music]